Imagina que estás en una cafetería de París,
tomando un café con tu mejor amigo.
A un francés de la mesa de a lado le cobran
5.30 euros por una taza de café y un pan dulce.
Después, cuando tú pides la cuenta,
a ustedes les cobran 14 euros por dos tazas de café
y dos panes de dulce.
¿Puedes obtener el precio de cada taza de
café y de cada pan de dulce, resolviendo
un sistema con ecuaciones lineales de dos
variables, usando esta información?
Si es que sí,
¿cuál es la solución?
Si es que no,
¿cuál es la razón de que no puede resolverlo?
Así que como siempre, lo primero que vamos
a hacer es tratar de definir variables, entonces,
voy a usar otra vez "x" y "y".
Sea "x" igual al precio de una taza de café.
Mientras que voy a decir que "y"
es igual a precio del pan dulce,
que por cierto, aquí en esta foto tenemos un cuernito, entonces el precio del cuernito.
Ahora, el problema me dice que tenemos que
obtener el precio de la taza de café
y del pan de dulce
usando un sistema de ecuaciones,
así que vamos a ver
qué me dice la primera oración.
Dice que tú estás con un amigo...
¡Ah si claro, aquí está!
Que había un francés en la mesa de a lado
y al francés le cobraron por una taza de café
y por un pan de dulce, 5.30 euros,
entonces "x" más "y", es decir, una taza de café
más un pan de dulce, lo que cuesta cada uno
de ellos, me dio 5.30 euros,
esto es lo que le cobraron al francés.
Ahora,
¿cuánto les cobraron a ustedes?
Tanto a ti como a tu mejor amigo.
Dice bueno, ustedes consumieron dos tazas
de café y dos panes de dulce
y entonces les cobraron 14 euros,
¿esto cómo lo escribimos en matemáticas?
Bueno, dos tazas de café, entonces voy a
multiplicar al precio de una taza de café por 2,
porque consumimos 2 tazas de café
más 2 pan de dulce, entonces voy a multiplicar
lo que cuesta un pan de dulce por 2
y esto me tiene que dar igual a 14 euros.
"2x" más "2y" es igual a 14.
Y bueno, hay múltiples formas de resolver
este sistema de ecuaciones,
puede ser por igualación,
suma y resta, lo que sea...
Pero a mí se me ocurre que es mucho más
fácil hacerlo por suma y resta,
porque aquí tenemos el doble de "x" y el doble de "y",
así que lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar
esta ecuación de aquí por 2 y después,
restar una ecuación de la otra,
así que si multiplico la primera ecuación por 2,
me va a quedar "2x" más "2y"
es igual a 5.30 por 2, lo cual es, 10.60...
sí, sí, sí...
10.60...
Y con razón...
si el francés consumiera 2 tazas de café
y dos panes de dulce, él pagaría solamente 10.60, mientras que nosotros estamos pagando 14 euros.
¿Qué pasó aquí?
Bueno, lo que a mí se me ocurre es que como
nosotros nos encontramos en un café de París,
a las personas que son de Francia les cobran
un precio más económico que las personas
que son extranjeras, es por eso que entonces
el francés paga menos
por cada uno de los artículos
de lo que nosotros pagamos.
Y bueno, esto tiene toda la lógica
también matemática.
Fíjate bien que si nosotros queremos resolver
este sistema de ecuaciones,
vamos a llegar a algo
que no tiene nada de sentido
y para esto lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar la ecuación de abajo por menos, entonces voy a multiplicar...
no, espera, espera...
mejor voy a multiplicar directo todo por menos,
entonces le voy a cambiar el signo a todo,
"-2x" menos "2y" esto es igual a -10.60,
y ahora si,
¿qué me va a quedar de sumar estas dos ecuaciones?
Te vas a dar cuenta de que no hay una "x",
ni una "y" que cumplan simultáneamente estas
dos ecuaciones, porque si yo sumo estas dos
ecuaciones, estos dos se van a ir,
"2x" menos "2x", "2y" menos "2y" también se van, entonces del lado izquierdo me queda 0,
mientras que del lado derecho
me queda 3.40,
¿y cuando 0 es igual a 3.40?
Nunca.
Lo que quiere decir
que no existe una "x" mágica
que me ayude a resolver
este par de ecuaciones.
Este sistema de ecuaciones
no tiene solución
y bueno, no tiene solución
porque al francés le cobran un poco menos
por ser originario de ese lugar.